[Music]
Peter Pan is arguably one of Disney's
best films but there are some dark
things behind the story that you may not
have known stay tuned to find out why
Peter Pan may not be the good guy you
thought he was new around here don't
forget to give this video a big thumbs
up and subscribe to the things for more
great content like this now onto 10 dark
secrets in Peter Pan Disney doesn't want
you to know changing stories kids aren't
really big fans of change are they
that's why whenever they have to change
schools or a new baby comes into the
family there are usually some big issues
that come up but with Disney films kids
usually don't have to worry about change
the film start out the same way every
time
but Peter Pan wasn't always so reliable
in fact the film actually started out as
a play then it was turned into a novel
in 1911 called Peter and Wendy the play
first opened in London in 1904 the weird
thing about the story though was that it
was always changing its creator JM
Barrie was always updating it the script
changed every year the version of the
story that we've all seen is the one
from the late 1950s early 1960s can you
imagine if Disney movies changed like
that part of the appeal of them is that
you can watch them when you're young and
then come back when you're older and
still get the same joy and excitement
out of the storylines that you had when
you were a kid if the story changed
every year we wouldn't feel nearly the
same amount of joy that we do now the
movies would never be classics because
classics don't change fairy dust
you'd never think of Peter Pan as being
a movie that is not safe for kids to
watch the whole object of the movie is
to be a kid forever so of course the
movie has to be okay for kids to watch
unfortunately that wasn't always true
back the original story of Peter Pan is
actually a bit of a health hazard for
children don't know what we're talking
about okay let's break it down so in the
original versions of the story Peter Pan
and the lost boys could fly on their own
this caused kids who knew the story to
try their own hand at flying there were
reports popping up everywhere of kids
jumping from their beds and trying to
fly of course all these kids soon
learned that they could not fly but not
before they were left with injuries to
combat this JM Barrie added fairy dust
to the story and the newer versions of
the tale fairy dust is a necessary
component of flying this made the story
much safer for kids to watch since no
kids have their
own little fairy or fairy dust lying
around there were way fewer injuries
after this element was added to the
story The Lost Boys when watching the
film you probably thought how great it
would be to be a lost boy to never have
to grow up to stay young and have fun
forever but that eternal youthfulness
may not have been all that it seemed in
fact there is one line in the story that
people tend to just skip over but this
one line shows what might be a horrible
horrible truth going on behind the
scenes the line in the story says the
boys on the island very of course in
numbers according as they get hurt and
so on and when they seem to be growing
up which is against the rules
Peter thins them out but at this time
there were six of them counting the
twins as - did you hear that when they
start to age Peter spins them out as in
Peter gets rid of them some users on
reddit have suggested that the way Peter
gets rid of the Lost Boys is by dropping
them over crocodile infested waters
which is pretty morbid and not really
something we want to spend too much time
dwelling on we just can't believe that
Peter Pan may be a murderer
but it is right there in the line of the
story of course Disney didn't include
that in the film hating adults okay so
we all know that Peter Pan was obsessed
with staying young forever which in
itself is a little creepy
he probably should have been seeing a
therapist to work out his issues of
never wanting to age anyway Peter's fear
and disdain of growing older may have
caused him to actually hate adults and
we don't mean in the normal I don't like
adults because they have too many rules
way we mean like really hate them there
is a line in the story that reads as
soon as he got inside his tree he
breathed intentionally quick short
breaths at the rate of about five to a
second he did this because there is a
saying in the neverland that every time
you breathe a grown-up dies and Peter
was killing them off vindictively as
fast as possible see Peter was kind of
evil even if you don't like adults you
shouldn't be out to get rid of them all
what kind of horrible person does that
Peter apparently we definitely see why
Disney left this part of the story out
we can't imagine that parents would have
allowed their children to watch the film
if that part had been included stealing
boys the author of the Peter Pan story
may have actually been a much darker
version of Peter Pan in real life why
because apparently he stole his own
crew of lost boys basically what JM
Barrie did was manipulate his way into
the lives of two people named Sylvia and
Arthur Llewelyn Davies the Davies had
three children
George Jack and Peter throughout the
lives of the kids JM spent lots of money
on gifts for the family and would spend
lots of time playing with the boys
having fun in the park and making up
stories later Arthur and Sylvia both
died of cancer within a three year time
span of each other when this happened
Barry took guardianship of the boys the
real kicker is that he forged Sylvia's
will so that he could take custody of
the kids
none of the children's actual relatives
ever objected to him taking the children
years later once Peter had grown up he
said that the whole thing with Barry
taking custody of him and his brothers
was the most pathetic and ludicrous
thing that someone could have done
either this is an extremely sad tale or
a very creepy one perhaps JM really
didn't want the best for the kids but
forging a will and lying is not the way
to go about it
relationship to Michael okay we may have
to take back what we said about JM maybe
wanting what was best for the boys
because when you look deeper into the
story the whole thing just gets creepier
and creepier JM really loved taking
pictures of two of the boys Michael and
George sometimes they would be wearing
costumes that he made and sometimes they
would be wearing no clothes at all if a
grown man stole children and then was
always taking pictures of them today
that would have raised several flags but
for some reason no one really seemed to
be concerned he even wrote about his
weird relationship with the boys in this
book the little white bird even though
the book described him doing some weird
things it was really popular when it was
published to make matters worse in June
of 1908 JM wrote a letter to Michael for
his eighth birthday that was so creepy
it gives us chills it said I wish I
could be with you and your candles you
can look on me as one of your candles
the one that burns badly dear Michael I
am very fond of you but don't tell
anybody um gross
never loving JM Barrie did get married
maybe you're thinking that after his
marriage he the boys and his wife were
one big happy family that isn't the case
at all in fact JM may have never even
loved his wife at all his wife Mary
Ansel once wrote love
and its fullest sense could never be
felt by him or experienced isn't that
horrible can you imagine being married
to a man who could never feel love I
wonder what made her marry him in the
first place
it is also wildly believe that JM was
unable to have children which may have
been part of why he felt he needed to
steal some eventually Mary grew tired of
being unloved by her husband and sought
affection somewhere else she ended up
having an affair with one of her
husband's friends which led to their
divorce Disney doesn't tell you this
morbid backstory about the creator of
their beloved film there have been
movies about JM Barrie and most of this
stuff is left out he is painted as quite
a kind man and not at all someone who is
unable to love as his former wife Mary
thought everyone left ok this is the
last one about JM Barrie we just had to
point this out if you're on the fence
about the character of the creator of
the play consider this everyone left him
when George and Peter were old enough
they both volunteered to serve in World
War one many said that this was the boys
way of getting away from JM sadly George
passed away in the war while he was in
Belgium he was only 21 when Michael was
21 he passed away as well but in this
case he took his own life he drowned
himself in the River Thames Peter the
last surviving adoptive son of JM also
took his own life he passed away at 63
when he stepped in front of a train
before he passed away he destroyed most
of the letters that his adopted father
had written to him and his brothers he
said that the letters were simply too
much taking all of these things into
account you can see that the real story
behind Peter Pan is really tragic now
that's probably why Disney tried to
sweep it under the rug who would allow
their children to watch a movie created
by such a strange and possibly horrible
man
the original story in the original story
of Peter Pan he was only a week old baby
when he left home and he never aged past
that in the story Peter thought that his
mother would always love him and always
would leave a window open for him to
return because he wasn't worried about
losing his mother's affection he's been
all of his time playing with the fairies
and the birds and never worried about
going back home the problem is that
while Peter is away time is still
clicking forward when he finally does
decide to go back home he's too late his
mother has barred the windows so that he
can no longer enter and to make matters
worse she has a new baby Peter then
believes that his mother's love was not
unconditional
as he once thought and he'd been
replaced when you view the story like
this it's quite sad no one wants to
believe that their mother could just get
over them and move on no one wants to
believe that if they play outside for
just a bit too long that maybe when they
come back their mother will have a new
baby
maybe that's why Disney added all those
frills and feel-good moments to the
story so that people could come away
from the movie feeling good and not
depressed Peter Pan is the villain in
both the book in the play Peter Pan has
no problem with murdering people he does
so to the Pirates pretty easily and then
as we mentioned earlier he may have also
been doing the same to the Lost Boys who
got too old in the book he also alters
the bodies of the Lost Boys so they can
all fit through the tree holes to get to
their underground dwellings how he
alters their bodies isn't really
specified but we can only think that
he's probably cutting off things or
breaking things so they can fit into
smaller places another thing that makes
him a villain is that he can't tell the
difference between what's real and
what's fake sometimes he gives the last
voice for 10 meals and then won't
believe them when they say they're still
hungry in addition to this The Lost Boys
are always in serious danger in the play
and the book but instead of being
concerned for them Peter usually finds
the danger entertaining
he only saves the boys but it isn't
saved them because he loves them he does
it so that he can have a chance to save
them again and show off how clever he is
isn't that just a little bit irritating
that's it for 10 dark secrets in Peter
Pan Disney doesn't want you to know were
you surprised by any of these secrets
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching
[Music]